the u.s is sending another billion
dollars worth of ammunition and military
equipment to ukraine it's the largest
single drawdown from u.s military
stockpiles so far this comes amid
increased fighting in the south and east
of the country charlie dagetta is in
miko live a front-line city on ukraine's
south coast charlie good morning
good morning nate that is the trauma
ward of a hospital bomb just over a week
ago amazingly nobody was hurt weapons
weapons weapons and more weapons that's
the message we got from the top general
here ahead of a massive
counter-offensive in a showdown for this
port city
we spoke with major general dimitro
marchenko in the rubble of the regional
government headquarters
no one here needs reminding that russia
still holds the upper hand in heavy
weapons
the general told us that for every 100
shells the russians fire at the city his
forces can respond with only 10. but the
kremlin's forces are running out of
precision-guided missiles like the one
that destroyed this building in the
early days of the war
general marchenko gave us a long list of
weapons being unleashed on the city from
long-range missiles to soviet-era
rockets from the 60s even firing
anti-aircraft munitions at buildings
and they're using cluster bombs here too
[ __ ]
the general credited americans supplied
high mars for striking weapons depots
and severing supply lines far behind
russian front lines
what difference has the jaimar weapon
system made for the war effort
it's one of the main factors why we've
kept our ground
and started taking advantage on the
field
but the russian onslaught has been
relentless the front-line town of
bachmut has suffered ferocious
bombardment the shelling of the eastern
donbass region's main water supply has
left residents in the city of sloveons
without water for two months
adding to the suffering in cities under
siege
this city comes under nightly
bombardment it was hit again last night
and early this morning explosions off in
the distance the general told us it
happens around three times a day hitting
random civilian targets even hospitals
gail charlie dagetta reporting from
ukraine we thank you i